it's called the happiest place on earth
Walt Disney dreamt up Disneyland as a
theme park that adults and kids could
enjoy together the park opened in 1955
but getting to that point was no easy
task
from this Bisbee Disney himself had to
get out and sell his unique idea to
investors now we want you to share with
us our latest and greatest dream I want
a site of 240 acres in the city of
Anaheim we've begun to build Disneyland
the price now an item that helped Disney
bring his dream to life is going up for
auction
the original concept art for the park
itself three and a half feet tall by
five and a half feet wide the Incan
pencil drawing was put together by
artist Herr Reimann
and Disney himself during a marathon
brainstorming weekend back in 1953 the
original drawing doesn't look that much
different from the park today it
includes a Main Street USA Fantasyland
and Tomorrowland the map came into the
possession of former Disney employee
granade current after Walt gifted to him
back in 1955 I said we're gonna do the
math and can I have it
and then won't turn you're gonna have it
now this important piece of Disney
history can be all yours if you have a
bank account the size of the Matterhorn
which I do not by the way bidding opens
at half a million dollars the map could
fetch up to a million dollars and we
want to give special thanks to the van
Eaton gallery in Sherman Oaks California
for sharing that amazing really nice
gift there for Walt Disney yeah it's
amazing to think what came out of that
you know from that drawing one vision
and it turns into so much